good meat that two men killed yes 6 l
react
[Music]
watching the tutorial about what
Africans not time that I had come back
to it and I thought the only secure in
here too and I come felt out of you the
next step was working there with people
[Music]
you
I'm watching yes six tutorial the recipe
project I want to finish i want to write
in es6 health learn more about he had
sex because i didn't do it last year i
didn't use it last year she's another
xaverian for today and fuse day was
devoted to TK 6 the thought that comes
to my mind is that we postpone learning
the things very often what happens like
is not the time it will be too difficult
look at it it seems to be like changing
writing the CSS to sass so it's like
going stepfather and making things
easier and writing less code and between
the same results but the thing is that
we are afraid and lazy sometimes they
are looking for the excuses and we avoid
learning something new to play because
it's new or the thing that's very
difficult sure I'll have to default some
time to introduce be GF 6 in my code and
remember about them and for sure we were
checking into x but the thing sometimes
are really easy and we make them really
difficult because we are lazy or we
simply don't want to try because knew
this was my case too with es6
[Music]
it's Wednesday I respect her up at the
project in order to feed that file that
I produced separately from those that
will go to the production server today
and finally starting working on moving
their components from layout in to react
someone's into changing their site
includes we are displayed
[Music]
you
do
Oh
[Music]
and
hmm
[Music]
at the end of the week and so what I
managed to do in this up this week I
love the content right now with react so
as you see in this create recipe I
gather a terror component tax component
image component and they are totally
bulbs with react right now so these
powerful colors are react components
let's see it in the code so i divided
the content from HTML into components
and pages conference right now are
almost ready and these are the smaller
blocks and they use the prop and they
are loaded dynamically they change the
analogy I use prop the majority of them
to pass the data
because this component will be reusable
so states where in the best choice here
in order to make the components reusable
I had to make conditioning life intact
taxes the element here so depending on
the view that are rendered in a
different way for example if the facts
are editable so they are and you create
or addition mode and I add them there in
class taught which places them to the
left but if they are in their home page
view or in the recipe view of this of
the details where I look at the details
of the recipe they have the alignment to
the right the data is trying their
dynamic lee except that dynamically so
this far just almost done i think both
pages right now the top-level pages
still needs to be done next week this is
another level so pages where details
addition and hold you is there component
so i use these stuff however pages as
the top level needs much more logic and
whack next week and i am going to come
back to it I think that assessee I will
do the routine in order to be able to
move between pages and change the
content dynamically and later I will
come back to their logic and local
storage because what also one of the
requirements for this project appear
number eight all new recipes I act and
stay tuned my brother local storage if I
refer to page there was people still be
dead so routine and the logic at the top
level of pages so here and local storage
still needs to be done to need to be
dealt with Mexico pointing away recipe
box products
[Music]
celibacy make your fat asses and
applause to the back see how far the end
result keep on doing a see you next week
[Music]